Tasha: 好玩吗
Jake:好玩很重要这个很重要
Jake:这个边上我要挤很多
Jake: I need to squeeze a lot on this side.
Tasha: 是吧其实我觉得
Tasha: Right, actually, I think...
Tasha: 如果你能把周围一圈再挤下来
Tasha: If you can squeeze around the whole circle...
Tasha: 然后再抹的平一点
Tasha: 就像蛋糕
Jake:周围
Jake:就是我要把这个都给填上
Jake: So I need to fill all of this.
Tasha: 算了算了
Lucia: 难度好像有点高
Tasha: 算了杨老师
Tasha: 哎你看你应该把它转一圈来的
Tasha: Hey, you should've turned it around.
Jake:转它一圈
Tasha: 这样它就不会往上跑了
Jake:有道理
Tasha: 好一点不带浪费
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:来了
Jake: Here it comes
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈都在吃
Jake: Hahaha, everyone's eating
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈等饿了谁敢吃啊
Lucia: Haha, who's daring enough to eat when they're hungry
Tasha: 不是谁敢吃啊
Tasha: It's not about who dares to eat it
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 对呀靠你了
Jake:来吧哈哈哈哈
Jake: Come on, hahaha
Lucia: 来吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Come on, hahaha
Lucia: 这是啥呀
Tasha: 救命啊
Tasha: Help!
Tasha: 我来我你来你来你来
Jake:我来哈哈
Jake: I'll do it, haha.
Jake:你来你来
Jake: You do it.
Jake:你来我来我来
Jake: You do it, I'll do it.
Lucia: 等一下我先给你稍微整理一下啊
Lucia: Wait a minute, let me tidy it up for you first.
Jake:好玩吗好玩好
Jake: Is it fun, is it fun?
Lucia: 不过
Lucia: But...
Lucia: 我觉得我可能跟你没法整理的很平坦
Lucia: I don't think I can make it very flat for you.
Lucia: 剩下的就要靠您自己了
Lucia: The rest is up to you.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 刮腻了是吗
Shure: Are you done scraping?
Lucia: 就是挤完之后给他上面这弄平了
Lucia: Just after squeezing it, make the top flat.
Lucia: 这一会要弄不平
Lucia: This part needs to be evened out.
Lucia: 您呢自己弄弄哈
Lucia: You can try it yourself.
Jake:我试试我试一下我看有多深哈哈哈
Jake: Let me try, let me see how deep it is, haha.
Lucia: 呀别别哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 咱这好奇心用在合适的地方吧
Lucia: Let's use our curiosity in the right place.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 他想看看上面这层有多深
Lucia: He wants to see how deep the top layer is.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake:好的好的好的好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay, alright.
Jake:我来了来了
Jake: I'm coming, I'm coming.
Tasha: 我已经迫不及待了
Tasha: I can't wait any longer.
Lucia: 哈哈还是得有经验的
Lucia: Haha, you need experience for this.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 票子是不是就像一个蛋糕了哈哈
Tasha: Is money like a cake? Haha.
Lucia: 这让我想到那个
Lucia: This reminds me of that...
Lucia: 就是哈利波特里面
Lucia: You know, in Harry Potter...
Lucia: 海格给哈利做那个蛋糕
Lucia: When Hagrid made Harry that cake.
小薇 ：哦前段时间回来好利来卖那个
Tasha: Oh, recently Holiland was selling that.
Lucia: 对对对是的
Lucia: Yes, yes, exactly.
Lucia: 就是第一次做蛋糕的人
Lucia: Like the first time someone makes a cake...
Lucia: 做出来的蛋糕差不多就长那样
Lucia: It looks pretty much like that.
Lucia: 我现在相信了
Lucia: I'm totally convinced now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: i'm totally convinced now
Lucia: I'm totally convinced now.
Jake:差不多啊
Jake: Pretty much.
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: That's nice.
Lucia: 整挺好整挺好
Lucia: That's nice, that's nice.
Jake:整挺好我再整整
Jake: It's nice, I'll fix it up more.
Jake:我真想知道他有多高
Jake: I really want to know how tall he is.
Lucia: 不是吧
Lucia: No way.
Jake:我刚刚好歹要这个东西我没整
Jake: I just needed this thing, but I didn't fix it.
Lucia: 啊那你们现在几点
Lucia: Ah, what time is it for you guys now?
Jake:色泽水深
Jake: Color and depth of water.
Lucia: 水深2.二点几
Lucia: Water depth is around 2.2.
Lucia: 马克图的那个2.5英尺
Lucia: The mark is at 2.5 feet.
Tasha: 我们已经毫来毫不在意
Lucia: We're completely indifferent now.
Tasha: 杨老师吃吗
Jake:吗啊吃一个
Jake: Come on, have one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 你冷静一点
Lucia: Calm down.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Tasha: 哎到底了到底了
Lucia: 先看这水深
Lucia: Look at this depth first.
Lucia: 没有2.5英尺
Lucia: It's not 2.5 feet.
Tasha: 哇有点像蛋糕啊
Tasha: 说实话不像汉堡
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Eh, it’s okay, it’s okay.
Jake:谢谢鼓励
Jake: Thanks for the encouragement.
Lucia: 杨老师这技术可以嗯
Lucia: Jake, your skills are pretty good.
Tasha: 哈哈不是这个有点丑吧
Lucia: 叫什么叫碗大厦于江青哈哈哈
Lucia: What's it called? The Great Bowl Mansion over the Yangtze, hahaha.
Jake:主要问题是不是我多多的要存了
Jake: The main issue is, did I make too much?
Tasha: 可能是
Jake:我觉得也是
Jake: I think so too
Tasha: 不太好弄是吧
Jake:嗯就不太够
Jake: Yeah, it's just not enough
Jake:建材不够
Jake: Not enough materials
Jake:就外边的漆就不刷了吧就是
Jake: Let's not bother painting the outside then
Tasha: 我来拯救一下
Jake:好怎么拯救
Jake: Okay, how do we save this?
Lucia: 这是啥
Tasha: 刮好了吗
Jake:我可以没有刮好对吗
Jake: I may not be done, right?
Tasha: 好那就等你刮好
Tasha: 然后开始在外形上拯救
Lucia: Then let's start fixing the shape
Jake:怎么拯救
Jake: How do we fix it?
Tasha: 首先搞颜色
Lucia: First, work on the color
Tasha: 然后搞蛋糕哦
Lucia: Then, work on the cake
Lucia: 我再出去喝两口壮壮胆
Lucia: I'll go out for a drink to calm my nerves
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 这些杯子是随便哪一个用都行的
Lucia: You can use any of these cups
Katrina: 有一个是我的
Katrina: One of these is mine
Lucia: 哪一个呀
Shure: 知道吗
Shure: You know?
Katrina: 这个
Lucia: 好的用这个
Lucia: 喝两口再进去弄那个蛋糕
Shure: 就是跟你搜手
Shure: Just like how you searched hands.
Katrina: 蛋糕做到哪一步了
Katrina: How's the cake coming along?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 现在用刮刀刮上了奶油
Lucia: Now, I'm spreading the cream with a spatula.
Lucia: 要进去看一眼吗
Lucia: Do you want to take a look?
Katrina: 看
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia: 杨老板在刮
Lucia: Jake is spreading.
Lucia: 我觉得挺不错的
Lucia: I think it's pretty good.
Lucia: 本来是我刮来着
Lucia: I was supposed to spread it.
Lucia: 但是他这个
Lucia: But he...
Lucia: 呵呵水平非常高超
Lucia: Haha, his level is very high.
Katrina: 看听说你的水平很高超
Katrina: Look, I heard your level is very high.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:是像吗哈哈
Jake: Does it look like it? Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈像
Katrina: Hahaha, it does.
Lucia: 像不像那个
Lucia: Does it look like that...
Lucia: 就是哈利波特里面
Lucia: Like in Harry Potter...
Katrina: 嗯哈利波特
Katrina: Hmm, Harry Potter.
Lucia: 海格给哈利做的那个蛋糕
Lucia: The cake Hagrid made for Harry.
Katrina: 对啊对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 巧克力粉吗
Lucia: Is that cocoa powder?
Jake:画龙点睛画蛇点睛
Jake: Adding the finishing touches.
Tasha: 到底想说什么
Jake:就就牛逼牛逼好哈
Jake: Impressive, impressive, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈这这这俩
Lucia: Haha, these two...
Lucia: 这俩词完全是不同的意思啊
Lucia: These two words have completely different meanings.
Lucia: 你可考虑好
Lucia: You better think it through.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 哇
Lucia: 神来之笔
Lucia: Genius move.
Jake:是
Katrina: 你有开甜品店吗
Lucia: 拍照拍照
Lucia: Take a picture, take a picture.
Katrina: 嗯我手机撂哪去了
Tasha: 哦这里面还有一个袋子我说怎么搞不出来
Shure: 给他一个特写吧
Shure: Give him a close-up shot.
Shure: 杨老板回个头
Shure: Jake, turn around.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯不好意思是不是挡着了
Shure: 很棒
Shure: Very nice.
Tasha: 不洒了差别很大吗
Shure: 这是我的室友们
Shure: These are my roommates.
Shure: 这是我的被美女包围的室友们
Shure: These are my roommates surrounded by beauties.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 掉了掉
Katrina: It fell, it fell.
Shure: 然后这个就是
Shure: And then this is...
Katrina: 滑下来了怎么了
Katrina: It slipped down, what's wrong?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好我来拯救他
Jake: Okay, I'll save it.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: 行行
Jake:好我也觉得行
Tasha: 行好拜拜
Tasha: 我在做蛋糕呢
Tasha: 嗯我晚一点和你说你先发给我吧
Tasha: 嗯好拜拜
Jake:这么忙
Tasha: 有点紧急情况
Tasha: 他们明天答辩呢
Jake:哦
Katrina: 好香啊
Tasha: 好了
Katrina: 当当当当
Katrina: Ta-da-da-da!
Katrina: 给个特写
Katrina: Give it a close-up.
Tasha: 杨老师做的真好看
Lucia: 切吧
Lucia: Cut it.
Shure: 给你看看作者
Shure: Let me show you the author.
Lucia: 做一个
Lucia: Make one.
Tasha: 你可以用这个切
Tasha: You can use this to cut.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Shure: 切切切这历史性的一刀吧
Shure: Cut this historic slice.
Jake:怎么切切
Jake: How do I cut it?
Tasha: 随便你啊
Tasha: However you like.
Tasha: 你想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: Cut it however you want.
Shure: 你看5个就不好切
Shure: You see, five pieces are hard to cut.
Shure: 这这时候就就可以问AI一个问题
Shure: At this time, you can ask AI a question.
Shure: 我们放几个他更好切一些
Shure: How many pieces should we cut to make it easier?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：好吵啊修硕你好吵啊
Shure: So noisy, so noisy.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈怎么能嫌弃我呢
Shure: Haha, how can you dislike me?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎后面这个小心
Lucia: Hey, careful with the back.
其他人：你一天说的话够我一个星期说的话了
Shure: You talk more in a day than I do in a week.
Shure: 留点面子留点面子免提呢免提呢
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 来来来杨老板吃串
Jake:好 没手了
Shure: 给你们放这了
Jake:好谢谢你
Jake:不敢下手
Jake: Afraid to start.
Shure: 历史性的一刀
Shure: Historic cut.
Shure: 哎呀妈呀
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh my goodness, haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 好像没给这盘子剁碎了然后把
Shure: It seems like this dish isn't chopped up properly
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈快刀斩乱麻
Lucia: Haha, quick and messy
Shure: 哎呀我天呐
Shure: Oh my gosh
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright
Katrina: 爆浆了
Shure: 所以你在干什么
Shure: So what are you doing?
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my
Katrina: 高楼大厦崩塌了
Katrina: The tall buildings are collapsing
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful
Katrina: 紧急维修
Katrina: Emergency repairs
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈紧急维修
Katrina: Hahaha, emergency repairs
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Katrina: 紧急公关
Katrina: Crisis management
Jake:大楼要导致去拿胶带糊
Jake: The building is going to collapse, go get some tape
Jake:我要不先切吧
Jake: Should I cut it first?
Katrina: 那我先今天晚上回来
Katrina: Okay, I'll come back tonight
Lucia: 也行切了再放草莓吧
Lucia: Yeah, cut it and then add the strawberries
Jake:对我这个也抵一下
Jake: Yes, I'll support it too
Tasha: 他已经完全失去人们的样子了
Tasha: He doesn't look human anymore
Jake:有好的有好的
Jake: There are some good ones.
Jake:虽然不多
Jake: Although not many.
Lucia: 最后一块是好的
Lucia: The last piece is good.
Jake:你现在这个样子像不像那什么
Jake: Do you look like something now?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 路路华福
Lucia: Lulu Hua Fu.
Lucia: 可丽饼
Lucia: Crepe.
Jake:可以是吧
Jake: Right, is that okay?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 对有点像
Lucia: Yeah, a bit like that.
Jake:我先放那先放这
Jake: I'll put this here first.
Lucia: 哎我觉得这个pink Champagne挺好喝的
Lucia: Hey, I think this pink Champagne is pretty good.
Lucia: 甜度很高我喜欢
Lucia: It's very sweet, I like it.
Jake:多少有点丑
Jake: A bit ugly, though.
Lucia: 可以挺好的
Tasha: 好吃吗好吃就行
Tasha: 哇好有这种高级料理的哈哈
Lucia: Wow, it really has that high-end cuisine feel, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Tasha: 不会夸就硬夸
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 这个倒还行哎
Tasha: 这个还行
Tasha: 你要放在一起吗
Tasha: Are you going to put them together?
Tasha: 就给一个人吃
Tasha: Just for one person to eat?
Jake:好再来一个
Jake: Alright, let's do one more.
Lucia: 咱这盘还够吗
Lucia: Do we have enough of this dish?
Tasha: 哎杨老板公关一下
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Tasha: 好这份提拉米苏你去做吧哈哈
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哪哪个
Jake: Which one?
Tasha: 没事这个做的很好
Jake:好这个还行
Jake: Alright, this one is okay.
Lucia: 嗯好看
Lucia: Yeah, looks good.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 就是那种这么大一个盘
Tasha: 然后里面就一个小点心的那种
Lucia: 哈哈哎
Lucia: Haha, hey.
Lucia: 对对对确实很高级
Lucia: Yeah, it's really fancy.
Lucia: 我咋觉得咱这盘子
Lucia: Why do I feel like this plate...
Lucia: 要不我上楼看看
Lucia: Should I go upstairs and check?
Lucia: all the kicks and all the lines you see fire in their eyes
Lucia: now she's stronger than you know
Lucia: 啊我又拿了几个盘子
Lucia: Ah, I got a few more plates.
Lucia: 稍等冲一下哈
Lucia: Hold on, let me rinse them.
Lucia: 哎呀咦咦咦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh, oh dear.
Jake:切蛋糕一般怎么切啊谢谢您
Jake: How do you usually cut a cake? Thank you.
Tasha: 哇这一般就是高级料理的样子
Tasha: Wow, this looks like high-end cuisine.
Jake:哎呀这东西不能放
Jake: Oh no, you can't put this here.
Jake:还有一个串是吧
Jake: There's another skewer, right?
Katrina: 请
Jake:把成品做成的原材料感觉
Jake: It feels like turning a finished product back into raw materials.
Jake:哈哈哈把成品做成的原材料
Jake: Hahaha, turning a finished product back into raw materials.
Lucia: 怎怎么了
Lucia: What happened?
Jake:哈哈哈就是
Jake: Hahaha, exactly.
Jake:就是我觉得我好像一开始那个太阳
Jake: I feel like the sun at the beginning...
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:就是我一开始打的那个奶油
Jake: It's like the cream I whipped at first.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Huh?
Jake:打出来的挺开心的好
Jake: Whipped it happily, though.
Jake:像也这样
Jake: Just like this.
Lucia: 哈哈没事
Lucia: Haha, it's okay.
Lucia: 他短暂的作为成品存在了一会对
Lucia: It existed briefly as a finished product, right?
Jake:啊存在过存在过
Jake: Ah, it did exist, it did.
Jake:妙
Jake: Wonderful.
Jake:这个这个挺好
Jake: This is nice.
Lucia: 而且它作为成品的时候吧
Lucia: And when it was a finished product...
Lucia: 它是一种传统艺术的蛋糕
Lucia: It was a traditional art cake.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 现在切完之后呢
Lucia: Now after cutting it...
Lucia: 它成了一种当代艺术的蛋糕
Lucia: It became a contemporary art cake.
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Lucia: 所以说实际上是一种审美上的进步
Lucia: So, it's actually an aesthetic improvement.
Jake:哈哈我去我去
Jake: Haha, I'll go, I'll go.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 他退出文坛
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Huh
Lucia: 嗯可能就是
Lucia: Hmm, maybe it's just...
Jake:哎
Jake: Eh
Lucia: 咨询界少了一个乱说PPT的人才
Lucia: The consulting industry lost a talent who talks nonsense in PPT.
Jake:呀
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 哎现在盘子够了吗
Lucia: Hey, do we have enough plates now?
Jake:够了这个我吃
Jake: Yes, this one is for me.
Lucia: 够了这个我吃
Lucia: Yes, this one is for me.
Lucia: 哦居然够了
Lucia: Oh, it's actually enough.
Jake:这样够了
Jake: This should be enough.
Lucia: 嗯正好是我刚刚洗那盘
Lucia: Hmm, it's just the one I washed earlier.
Lucia: 要不我就用这个算了
Lucia: Maybe I'll just use this one.
Lucia: 感觉好像是
Lucia: It feels like it.
Jake:挺好
Jake:看看我的嗜好
Jake: Look at my hobby.
Jake:确实不太高
Jake: It's really not that tall.
Katrina: young
Jake:快长高啊
Jake: Grow taller quickly.
Lucia: 没事时给他多挤点奶油
Lucia: It's okay, just add more cream for him.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你弟弟
Jake: Your brother.
Tasha: 嗯
Jake:你弟弟怎么长高啊
Jake: How does your brother grow taller?
Jake:怎么长高啊
Jake: How to grow taller?
Tasha: 不知道啊
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 蛋糕来喽
Katrina: Cake is here.
Lucia: 这个是咱们的是吧
Lucia: This one is ours, right?
Lucia: OK我把这就放
Lucia: OK, I'll just put this here.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 现在是放下
Lucia: Now it's down.
Lucia: 看看他们外面进度如何了
Lucia: Let's see how their progress is outside.
Shure: 他不理我
Shure: He's ignoring me.
Shure: 杨老板怎么开始踱步了
Jake:为等饭吃
Jake: Waiting for food.
Shure: 饭大大厨
Shure: Food, the great chef.
Shure: 大厨怎么样啊大厨
Shure: How's the great chef doing?
Alice:太慢了我感觉这炭火一会就烧完了
Alice: Too slow, I feel like the charcoal will burn out soon.
Shure: 大厨这鸡爪
Alice:哎呦哈哈哈哈
Alice: Oh, hahaha.
Alice:如果要烤的话
Alice:碳是不要多点
Shure: 整个全部吧
Shure: 而且要铺高一点
Jake:要打碎
Shure: 他离离得感觉有点远是吧
Shure: He feels a bit far away, right?
Jake:没电了
Jake: No power.
Lucia: 认领一双筷子
Lucia: Claim a pair of chopsticks.
Jake:还切甜点呢
Tasha: 吃
Jake:吃
Lucia: 吃
Tasha: 基本上是你做的
Tasha: 好多
Jake:百分之二十吧
Tasha: 60%吧
Jake:这么多啊好
Lucia: 味道还是很好的
Lucia: The taste is still very good.
Lucia: 嗯好棒
Lucia: Hmm, that's great.
Jake:吃吗好吃
Jake: Do you want to eat it? It's delicious.
Tasha: 好
Lucia: 特别好
Lucia: It's really good.
Jake:我们都干了什么呀
Jake: What did we even do?
Jake:你在里面干了什么
Jake: What did you do in there?
Jake:奶油奶油
Jake: Cream, cream.
Lucia: 打奶油
Lucia: Whipping cream.
Jake:哦就是最后刮的那个
Jake: Oh, the last scrape.
Jake:嗯对基本上都是大概有OK
Jake: Yeah, pretty much that's it.
Lucia: 对基本上都是打奶油
Lucia: Yeah, mostly it's whipping cream.
Jake:我干了什么呀
Jake: What did I do?
Tasha: 您干了多了去
Jake:哈哈哈我一开始打了那个
Jake: Hahaha, I started with that...
Jake:打了那是什么呀
Jake: What was that thing I started with?
Tasha: 蛋清是吗
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 然后又
Jake:就是让他立起来
Jake: Just to make it stand up.
Jake:那是干嘛的啊
Jake: What's that for?
Tasha: 啊啊蛋糕胚
Jake:啊那是干嘛的呀蛋糕胚
Jake: Ah, what's that for? The cake base.
Tasha: 嗯口感还是很丰富的
Lucia: 我自己觉得超好吃
Lucia: I think it's super tasty.
Tasha: 打的奶油还是挺好吃的
Jake:嗯奶油好吃
Jake: Hmm, the cream is tasty.
Lucia: 谢谢老师夸奖哈哈哈
Lucia: Thanks for the compliment, teacher. Haha.
Lucia: 咱俩是不是得给老师点精神损失费啊
Lucia: Should we pay the teacher mental damages?
Lucia: 你说哈哈哈哈
Lucia: What do you think? Haha.
Jake:老师我给你烤肉去好吧
Jake: Teacher, I'll grill some meat for you, okay?
Tasha: 不用
Jake:老师你要吃什么肉
Jake: Teacher, what kind of meat do you want to eat?
Lucia: 嗯很棒很棒
Lucia: Hmm, great, great.
Tasha: 很棒很棒
Tasha: 接下来就是下一个
Lucia: 是不是要再打一些
Lucia: Should we make some more?
Tasha: 对淡奶油要再打一次
Tasha: 那个盆就不用洗了
Tasha: 嗯反正都打奶油好嘞
Lucia: 哦那行
Lucia: Oh, that's fine.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 然后还是称
Lucia: And then weigh it.
Tasha: 放在电子秤上
Lucia: 直接把盆放电子秤上
Lucia: Just put the bowl on the digital scale.
Tasha: 对
Lucia: 好的
Tasha: 觉得这个奶油甜度刚刚好啊
Jake: I think the cream's sweetness is just right.
Lucia: 我觉得可以
Lucia: I think it's fine.
Tasha: 那这样的话就还是按1:10的比例
Lucia: So, let's stick to the 1:10 ratio.
Lucia: 你觉得呢
Lucia: What do you think?
Lucia: 因为其实我还蛮爱吃甜的
Lucia: Because I actually really like sweet things.
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 所以对我来说我觉得是刚好OK的
Lucia: So for me, I think it's just okay.
Tasha: 有点少
Tasha: 再再来点
Tasha: OK我们奶油都用完了
Tasha: 我靠这是有用的东西
Lucia: 哦那是那个生蚝他们还没烤呢
Lucia: Oh, those oysters aren't grilled yet.
Lucia: 嗯准备出去了吗
Lucia: Hmm, are you ready to go out?
Tasha: 好像烤好了
Lucia: 好的
Tasha: 多少
Lucia: 灯怎么灭了
Lucia: Why did the light go out?
Jake:我来拿点肉过来
Tasha: 怎么分为室内喝室外了已经
Lucia: 哎差不多了吧
Tasha: 好的
Lucia: 那就先
Tasha: 等一下20多糖
Lucia: 哦好的
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 你就把这个先拿下来啊
Lucia: Just take this down first.
Tasha: 啊不用拿下来啊
Lucia: 但是那我怎么知道20克糖
Tasha: 现在不是200吗
Jake:给你们加肉
Lucia: 嗯好了刚好20
Lucia: 刚不是有个盘子好像
Lucia: Wasn't there a plate just now?
Jake:这这3个盘子是
Jake: These three plates are...
Tasha: OK拿着这个
Lucia: 呃那个盘
Lucia: Uh, that plate...
Lucia: 那那几盘还要冲一下
Lucia: Those few plates still need to be rinsed.
Lucia: 就是我刚拿下来本来要放蛋糕的
Lucia: I just took them down, was going to put the cake on them.
Jake:好冲一冲
Jake: Okay, rinse them.
Lucia: 但后来够了然后就没没再管他
Lucia: But then there were enough, so I didn't bother.
Jake:好那个串
Jake: Okay, that skewer...
Lucia: 这里还有个串
Lucia: There's another skewer here.
Jake:稍等
Jake:这叫啥名字来着
Jake: What's this called again?
Tasha: 纸杯蛋糕
Jake:就就叫这个
Jake: It's just called this.
Jake:嗯好的对
Jake: Uh, right.
Tasha: 我可以给他再丰富一点名字
Tasha: 叫纸杯戚风
Jake: It's called a chiffon cupcake.
Tasha: 爆浆巧克力蛋糕
Jake: Molten chocolate cake.
Jake:戚风是什么意思
Jake: What does chiffon mean?
Jake:戚风是指很蓬松的意思
Jake: Chiffon means very fluffy.
Lucia: 啊那我理解的差不多是对的
Tasha: 它可能打发打发过了
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈好的
Jake: Hahaha, okay
Jake:给他独特的风味
Jake: It gives it a unique flavor
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: 我来吧谢谢
Lucia: 哎咱垃圾垃圾桶是都拿过来一下吗
Lucia: Hey, should we bring the trash can over?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Tasha: 我们这好乱呀我已经不忍直视了
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 你去外面溜达一圈
Lucia: Go for a walk outside
Jake:哦你们都来了
Jake: Oh, you all came
Jake:好那吃吧
Jake: Alright, let's eat
Shure: 我又给AI数据集贡献了一些
Shure: I contributed some data to the AI dataset again
Shure: 人类在远程沟通了一些方式
Shure: Humans have some ways of remote communication
Shure: 真的我觉得应该跟你在这看色之前
Shure: Really, I think I should watch the colors with you
Katrina: 孜然粉就是在里面
Katrina: Cumin powder is inside
Shure: 每天远程当我的数据集
Shure: Remote every day as my dataset
Lucia: 我觉得我其实已经不太用得到筷子了
Lucia: I think I don't really need chopsticks anymore
Lucia: 徒手
Lucia: 加一
Lucia: Plus one
Tasha: 你想喝牛奶还是小青柠
Lucia: 我都可以
Lucia: I'm fine with both
Lucia: 我们那外面好像给大家都倒了
Lucia: It seems like they poured it for everyone outside.
Lucia: 那个小青
Lucia: That little Qing.
Lucia: 你喝吗
Tasha: 我不喝
Lucia: 那我们
Jake:喝什么
Jake: What are you drinking?
Tasha: 有没有人要喝养乐多
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
Tasha: 谁
Lucia: 我
Tasha: 还有吗
Jake:好喝
Jake:还缺筷子吗
Jake: Are we still missing chopsticks?
Jake:外面可能是
Jake: Maybe outside is...
Lucia: 外面应该不缺
Lucia: Outside should be enough.
Lucia: 因为我在外面放了6双
Lucia: Because I put out six pairs outside.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 可以先看一眼
Lucia: You can take a quick look.
Jake:砍一下
Jake: Chop it.
Shure: 这样可以吗
Shure: Is this okay?
Jake:他给我标过数据吗
Shure: 他没给你标过数据
Jake:好的
Shure: 他他
Shure: He, he...
Jake:唉有吗柠檬
Jake: Hey, is there lemon?
Lucia: 什么柠檬
Lucia: What lemon?
Lucia: 放了一点应该
Lucia: Should've added a bit.
Jake:噢对一开始给了一点
Jake: Oh right, gave a bit at the beginning.
Tasha: 你怎么半途而废了
Tasha: 打奶油了吗
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 等会让我再吃两口再回去打
Lucia: Wait, let me take a few more bites before going back to tag.
Shure: 智力低下的那种
Shure: Mentally challenged one. 社会问题
Lucia: 还像刚打到刚才那种程度好了
Lucia: It's still like we just hit it at that level.
Shure: 然后就是到我这个人的轮廓的时候
Shure: And then when it comes to my outline...
Jake:这些筷子我就洗一下用生的
Jake: I'll just wash these chopsticks and use the raw ones.
Shure: 人家都打human
Shure: Everyone else hits human.
Shure: 然后到我这打那个智力低下怎么说
Shure: But when it comes to me, I get hit by the low intelligence thing, what do you say?
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Jake:这些都是生的是吧
Jake: These are all raw, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:哦那我还是拿几个出来
Jake: Oh, then I'll still take a few out.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Katrina: 这这是手
Katrina: This, this is a hand.
Katrina: 这可以用
Katrina: This can be used.
Jake:这个是新的
Jake: This one is new.
Katrina: 这干净
Katrina: This is clean.
Jake:那你们领
Jake: Then you guys take one.
Jake:你们拿一个
Jake: You guys take one.
Jake:我还是洗两个
Jake:洗两双出来
Jake:你们领一双吧
Jake: You guys take a pair.
Tasha: 这这是谁的吗
Katrina: 这是新的
Tasha: 啊是吗看不出来他很新
Jake:我再拧三双吧
Jake: I'll take three more pairs.
Jake:那他克星也有
Jake: So his nemesis also has...
Lucia: 也行我把这个先放回去然后
Lucia: That's fine, I'll put this back first then.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Lucia: 咱筷子还够吗
Lucia: Do we still have enough chopsticks?
Jake:够够够够
Jake: Enough, enough, enough.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Lucia: 我要不把这双直接洗了算了
Lucia: Should I just wash this pair then?
Lucia: 嗯那也行那我现在
Lucia: Mm, that's fine, I'll...
Jake:一起我一起写
Jake: Together, I'll write it together.
Jake:你来打哎
Jake: You come hit, hey.
Lucia: 那我也回去打奶油了
Lucia: Then I'll go back and make the cream.
Jake:对对对你
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you...
Jake:你给师傅服务去
Jake: You go serve the master.
Tasha: 给谁服务师傅
Lucia: Serve who, master?
Jake:师傅
Jake: Master
Jake:嗯大师
Jake: Okay, Master
Lucia: 不用叠一起吧
Lucia: We don't need to stack them, right?
Lucia: 好像有一个盘子是我刚才用的
Lucia: I think there's a plate I just used
Lucia: 没事叠一起也行
Lucia: It's fine to stack them
Lucia: 无所谓了
Lucia: Doesn't matter
Tasha: 你已经逐渐掌握打奶油了
Lucia: 耶哈哈可以
Lucia: Yay, haha, it's good.
Tasha: 好玩吗
Lucia: 很不错有种DIY做蛋糕的感觉
Lucia: It's pretty nice, feels like DIY cake making.
Tasha: 多亏杨老板的倾情赞助
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 感觉好像差不多了
Lucia: Feels like it's almost done.
Lucia: 是吧好像
Lucia: Isn't it? Seems like it.
Lucia: 你试试看手感
Lucia: Try the texture.
Lucia: 我感觉好像差不多
Lucia: I feel like it's almost there.
Lucia: 耶哈哈哈
Lucia: Yay, hahaha.
Lucia: 获得一些技巧
Lucia: Learning some tips.
Lucia: 技巧加一
Lucia: Tips +1.
Lucia: 感谢老师
Lucia: Thanks, teacher.
Tasha: 呃哎呀
Lucia: 啊哦
Lucia: Ah, oh.
Lucia: 这个还没
Lucia: This one isn't done yet.
Lucia: 要不要叫杨老板进来切一下
Lucia: Should we ask Jake to come in and cut it?
Jake:杨老板
Lucia: 我去叫他
Lucia: 姚老板来切一下
Lucia: Jake, come cut it.
Lucia: 裱花袋
Lucia: Piping bag.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 您请哈哈哈
Lucia: Please, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 洗多个草莓吧
Lucia: OK
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 放到最上面
Lucia: 行
Lucia: 6个OK
Lucia: Six okays.
Lucia: 还是像那天那样切一下
Lucia: Just cut it like that day.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 刚刚好我们用了
Lucia: Just right, we used it.
Tasha: 刚用了6个
Lucia: Just used six.
Tasha: 现在还用哎
Lucia: Still using it now.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 好剩下8个可以吃了
Lucia: Alright, we've got 8 left to eat.
Lucia: 哈哈不是
Tasha: 剩下可以吃了对
Jake:我提着菜刀来了
Jake: I'm coming with the cleaver.
Tasha: 菜刀你在这里你
Tasha: 嗯给您我把草莓放这了
Jake:呃好我来切
Jake: Uh, okay, I'll cut it
Jake:好有一点用
Jake: Okay, it's somewhat useful
Tasha: 好
Lucia: 这个盘刚
Lucia: This plate just...
Lucia: 嗯我在好像没充过
Lucia: Hmm, I don't think I've ever charged it
Lucia: 啥充一下
Lucia: What, charge it up
Jake:没充过就这么装
Jake: Never charged, just installed like this
Tasha: 我应该从外撑这个袋子ok你这么喜欢
Tasha: DIY的话
Jake:我可会了
Jake: I got this.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:那继续
Tasha: 我连上了吗
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Jake:你没连上
Jake: You're not connected
Jake:好那就再连一下
Jake: Alright, let's connect again
Tasha: 哦这个是一个重要的环节
Jake: Oh, this is an important part
Jake:是吗对确实
Jake: Really? Yeah, for sure
Jake:展现两人的合作力对
Jake: Show the cooperation between the two
Jake:没电了哎
Jake: Out of battery, oh no
Jake:你你插你插管了吗
Jake: Did you plug it in?
Tasha: 插了呀
Jake: It's plugged in
Tasha: 那你你哎确实好了
Jake: Oh, okay, it's good now
Tasha: 好了20240418
Jake: Alright, 20240418
Jake:好来对一下
Jake: Okay, let's sync
Jake:对一下时间
Jake: Sync the time
Lucia: 哎呦
Lucia: Oh my
Lucia: 我傻了
Jake:好开始了
Jake: Alright, let's start
Jake:来看一眼
Jake: Let's take a look
Tasha: 看了
Tasha: Seen it
Jake:看了好
Jake: Seen it, okay
Jake:路亚我们也一起看一下
Jake: Let's also look at the VR together
Lucia: 嗯好的
Lucia: 但我看到的是反的
Lucia: 好了它现在正了
Jake:好可以
Jake: Alright, that's good.
Tasha: 继续
Tasha: Keep going.
Jake:呃在这
Jake: Uh, here...
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 有点烘焙天赋在身上的哈哈
Tasha: Maybe he has some baking talent, haha.
Jake:啊这么回事
Jake: Oh, that's what happened.
Jake:多少 0.5%技能点点吧
Jake: How much? 0.5% skill points, maybe.
Tasha: 技能点点满
Tasha: Maxed out skill points.
Jake:0.3%不能再多了
Jake: 0.3%, no more than that.
Jake:好好好可以
Jake: Okay, okay, sure.
Tasha: 切了吗哦对吧
Tasha: Did you cut it? Oh, right.
Jake:好我来骑
Jake: Okay, I'll ride.
Lucia: 刀还用这个刀吗
Lucia: Are we still using this knife?
Jake:啊我要骑
Jake: Ah, I need to ride.
Tasha: 啊你好忙呀哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, you are so busy, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊那我来挤哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah, then I'll squeeze in, hahaha.
Tasha: 那我来切
Tasha: Then I'll cut it.
Jake:那我干嘛
Jake: Then what do I do?
Lucia: 短暂的换一下任务
Lucia: Let's switch tasks briefly.
Jake:那我给你们加油
Jake: Then I'll cheer you guys on.
Lucia: 这个这个放在这
Lucia: Put this here.
Lucia: 这案板应该可以直接用
Lucia: This chopping board should work directly.
Tasha: 你们一人切一半吧
Tasha: You guys cut half each.
Tasha: 啊你们一人挤一半吧
Tasha: Ah, you guys squeeze half each.
Lucia: 嗯就就
Lucia: Hmm, just, just...
Jake:帮我救救市吧
Tasha: 救
Tasha: Save.
Jake:经济学大师
Jake: Economics expert.
Tasha: 救市是什么意思哦
Lucia: 就是吗你说的是哦 市嗯嗯
Lucia: 经济学还是有些解决不了的问题
Lucia: Economics can't solve everything.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 你知道吗哈哈
Lucia: You know? Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:4号真的好惨
Jake: Number 4 is really pitiful.
Lucia: 给他多放点奶油吧
Lucia: Give him more cream.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 咱给他放一个大的草莓或者
Lucia: Let's give him a big strawberry or...
Tasha: 我这个人还是很公平的
Tasha: I'm still very fair.
Tasha: 没有大葱哎
Tasha: There's no green onion.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:市场不允许
Jake: The market doesn't allow it.
Lucia: 底下
Lucia: Underneath.
Jake:像那么回事
Lucia: 特别香就是这么回事
Lucia: It smells great, that's what it is.
Jake:来请
Jake: Come on, please.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Tasha: 哇哇
Tasha: Wow, wow.
Jake:哇你这贴的好好看
Jake: Wow, you stuck it on really nicely.
Lucia: 哇好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks great.
Lucia: 这个草莓看着就让人觉得食欲大开
Lucia: This strawberry makes me so hungry just looking at it.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 大家都很会夸
Tasha: Everyone is really good at giving compliments.
Lucia: 这应该挤多点挤少点就像那天那样挤
Lucia: Should I squeeze out more or less like that day?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 你那个艺术蛋糕很艺术
Tasha: Your artistic cake is really artistic.
Tasha: 那天起的哈哈
Tasha: Like the other day, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈这个我觉得像在化鸟巢
Jake: Hahaha, I think it looks like you're making a bird's nest.
Lucia: 哈哈你看我每次都把它踢不断好怪哦
Lucia: Haha, you see, I can never break it off, it's so weird.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:这回弄水立方
Jake: This time make a Water Cube.
Lucia: 哎你就弄方一点是吧
Lucia: Oh, you just make it a bit more square, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 谁说不行呢
Lucia: Who says you can't?
Lucia: 但是他中间就会逐渐那个啥
Lucia: But it will gradually, you know...
Jake:哦你还得给他封个顶
Jake: Oh, you have to top it off.
Tasha: 空
Tasha: Empty.
Lucia: 对没事我会有草莓的
Lucia: Yeah, no worries, I'll have strawberries.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 这就叫凯恩斯经济学
Lucia: This is called Keynesian economics.
Lucia: 就我们只看短期
Lucia: We only look at the short term.
Lucia: 长远的这些另说
Lucia: The long term is another story.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 我们这个恩格尔系数拉满了
Tasha: Our Engel coefficient is maxed out.
Lucia: 我们这个恩格尔系数拉满了
Lucia: Our Engel coefficient is maxed out.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 就是啊我们的预算都用在吃上
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 有点丑就这样吧
Lucia: It's a bit ugly, so let's leave it.
Jake:不丑不丑
Jake: Not ugly, not ugly.
Lucia: 不过我觉得我们剩这个还挺多的是
Lucia: But I think we still have quite a lot left.
Lucia: 我前几个挤太少了
Lucia: I didn't squeeze enough in the first few.
Lucia: 没关系最后点缀
Lucia: 可以先我把这一圈给画完
Lucia: 画都画了
Lucia: It's already drawn.
Lucia: 给他封口吧
Lucia: Let's seal it up.
Lucia: 哎呀断了
Lucia: Oh no, it broke.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 那就将错就错了
Lucia: Let's just roll with it then.
Lucia: 大家都是很豁达的人
Lucia: Everyone here is pretty easygoing.
Tasha: 哇内外都在欢声笑语
Tasha: Wow, there's laughter inside and out.
Jake:哈哈来打听打听
Jake: Haha, let's find out.
Lucia: 外面进度怎么样了能吃吗
Lucia: How's the progress outside? Can we eat?
Jake:发生什么事了
Jake: What's going on?
Tasha: 里面的进度已经快结束了
Tasha: The inside is almost done.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:拿盘子吧
Alice: Grab a plate.
Lucia: 你看每次都拉不断好生气
Lucia: Look, it never breaks off, so frustrating.
Lucia: 微微你要挤一排吗
Lucia: Tasha, do you want to squeeze a row?
Lucia: 还是还是怎么样你挤吧
Lucia: Or, or what? You squeeze.
Tasha: 啊都可以
Tasha: Ah, whatever works.
Tasha: 你挤吧你们一人挤6个
Tasha: You squeeze, each of you do six.
Lucia: 好的谢谢老师
Lucia: Okay, thank you, teacher.
Jake:好我来去
Jake: Okay, I'm going.
Jake:我领肉去
Jake: I'll get the meat.
Jake:这盘子OK
Jake: This plate is OK.
Tasha: 我们不一起出去吃吗
Tasha: Aren't we going out to eat together?
Tasha: 挤完就出去吧
Tasha: Let's go out after squeezing.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 没事让他先领吧
Lucia: It's fine, let him go first.
Lucia: 挤可能还要挤
Lucia: Squeezing might take some time.
Lucia: 挤完还得一小会
Lucia: It might take a little while after squeezing.
Lucia: 然后咱就可以把这都端出去了
Lucia: Then we can take everything out.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay
Tasha: 哦这个记得不错谢谢
Tasha: Oh, this is nice, thanks
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake:我先把盘子送出去
Jake: I'll take the plates out first
Lucia: 我感觉我们一会是可能还是会有多的
Lucia: I feel like we might still have extras later
Lucia: 然后再补
Lucia: And then add more
Lucia: 我能直接吃咱的原材料吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can I just eat our raw materials? Hahaha
Tasha: 好了你的6个已领完
Tasha: Alright, your 6 are all claimed
Tasha: 今日任务领取完毕
Tasha: Today's task is completed
Tasha: 哈哈哈换下一位小朋友吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha, let's move on to the next kid, hahaha
Lucia: 今日任务
Lucia: Today's task
Lucia: 今日任务已完成
Lucia: Today's task is done
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Jake:好看
Tasha: 下一个小朋友
Tasha: Next kid
Tasha: 你多挤点
Tasha: How many more points do you have?
Jake:我想想我怎么把它给填满
Jake: I'm trying to figure out how to fill it up
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks
Lucia: 留给下一位小朋友的
Lucia: Leaving it for the next kid
Lucia: 这个这个余额还有很多哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, there's still a lot left, haha
Jake:那我一开始得使劲的挥霍一番
Jake: Then I should splurge a bit at the start
Lucia: 哈哈你真是P 人哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, you're such a spender, hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈你在
Lucia: Hahaha, you're
Tasha: 哈哈哈不知道他J挤什么救命啊
Tasha: Hahaha, I don't know why he's in such a hurry, help
Lucia: 你在蛋糕上做雕塑吗
Lucia: Are you making a sculpture on the cake?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Tasha: 女人你在玩火哈
Tasha: Woman, you're playing with fire.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How's it going?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha!
Lucia: 可以可以特别好
Lucia: It's great, really great.
Tasha: 特别好
Tasha: Really great.
Lucia: 就是有种不知所云的美感
Lucia: It has this kind of indescribable beauty.
Tasha: 那个那个那个杜上的那个小便池
Tasha: That, that, that urinal by Duchamp.
Lucia: 哈哈小便池哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, urinal, hahaha.
Tasha: 对你知道吗
Tasha: Yeah, you know?
Tasha: 就是杜尚杜尚他是一个艺术家
Tasha: It's like in the picture, he's an artist.
Jake:OK我知道了
Jake: OK, I got it.
Tasha: 他把小便池作为一件艺术品
Tasha: He made the urinal into an artwork.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 对然后名字叫全
Lucia: Yeah, and its name is "Fountain".
Lucia: 哈哈我见过这个艺术品的实物
Lucia: Haha, I've seen the real thing.
Lucia: 我在伦敦的泰特美术馆里
Lucia: At the Tate Gallery in London.
Lucia: 然后有一个小哥从旁边走过去
Lucia: And a guy walked past.
Jake:你去了
Lucia: 对然后他当时看了一眼这个
Lucia: Yeah, and then he looked at it.
Lucia: 然后跟他旁身边一个女生
Lucia: And talked to the girl next to him.
Jake:可能他女票
Jake: Maybe his girlfriend.
Tasha: 或者啊这是个便池吧
Tasha: 哈哈对但他觉得他是一个艺术品
Tasha: Haha, yeah, but he thinks he's a piece of art.
Lucia: 对要不来一个
Lucia: Yeah, how about we do one?
Jake:对要不来一个
Jake: Yeah, how about we do one?
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, ah.
Lucia: 别别别别
Lucia: No, no, no.
Lucia: 咱这是吃的
Lucia: We're eating here.
Jake:来一个艺术品
Jake: Do an art piece.
Tasha: 这个就这样子
Tasha: This one, just like this.
Tasha: 是吗好的那我给他来个小点的水果
Tasha: Right? Okay, then I'll get him a smaller piece of fruit.
Jake:那得竖竖上去
Jake: It needs to stand upright.
Tasha: 这样子啊
Tasha: Like this.
Tasha: 您来您来
Lucia: 这垫在后边他不用倒
Lucia: This pads the back, he doesn't need to fall.
Lucia: 哇哇我知道了
Lucia: Wow, wow, I got it.
Tasha: 我知道了您肯定是想表达这样的想法
Tasha: I got it, you definitely want to express this kind of idea.
Lucia: 猜你想搜哈哈哈
Lucia: Guess what you want to search, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎好看哎
Lucia: Wow, it looks good!
Jake:再来两个
Jake:要不不够了是吧
Jake: Otherwise, it won't be enough, right?
Tasha: 啊没关系还可以再切哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, it’s okay, we can cut more, hahaha.
Lucia: 没关系我来洗
Lucia: No worries, I'll wash it.
Jake:哦哦哈哈哈
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my goodness
Tasha: 哇直接变好看了哈哈
Tasha: Wow, it looks so much better now, haha
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Tasha: 真挺好
Tasha: Really good
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: Totally good
Jake:还能再做什么
Tasha: 奇怪的造型
Lucia: 没事不管是啥造型
Lucia: Doesn't matter what style it is
Lucia: 咱都能给他整成跟那一样的
Lucia: We can make it look just like that
Tasha: 对对都会整好看的
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, they'll all look great.
Tasha: 您放心吧
Tasha: Don't worry about it.
Jake:那我再来一个
Tasha: 好别做一样的
Tasha: Okay, but let's not make it the same.
Tasha: 发挥您的创造力
Tasha: Use your creativity.
Jake:哦好吧OK
Jake: Oh, okay, fine.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 不要再污蔑我了
Jake:哈哈哈没污蔑你
Tasha: 要干嘛好
Tasha: What do you want to do?
Tasha: 你还要再加一下是吗
Tasha: Do you want to add more?
Jake:再加一个
Jake: Add another one.
Tasha: 好加一个
Jake:不不不加加右边
Jake: No, no, no, add it to the right side.
Tasha: 就就这种不对称美感是吗
Tasha: So this asymmetrical beauty, right?
Jake:对对对好的好的
Jake: Yes, yes, that’s right.
Tasha: 啊好的好的
Tasha: Ah, got it, got it.
Tasha: 太会了
Tasha: So talented.
Lucia: 给大家来一些草莓补给
Lucia: I'll bring some strawberries for everyone.
Tasha: 我感觉就是很鲜明的能看出
Tasha: I feel it's very distinct, you can see...
Tasha: 这是两个人的风格
Tasha: It's the style of two people.
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:我刚刚架了一堵墙
Jake: I just built a wall.
Lucia: 啊可以
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 挺挺酷炫
Lucia: Pretty cool.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:然后干点啥呢
Jake: So what should we do next?
Lucia: 来观摩一下
Lucia: Let's check it out.
Lucia: 有什么吃的吗
Lucia: Is there any food?
Katrina: 嗯刚出炉的你吃吧
Lucia: 啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Alice:你把他们叫出来吧
Alice: You should call them out.
Alice:我感觉这会火挺好的
Alice: I think this will be pretty popular.
Lucia: 我们那边蛋糕马上就好了
Lucia: The cake on our side is almost ready.
Lucia: 已经进行到最后一步了
Lucia: It's already in the final step.
Lucia: 我跟他们说一声
Lucia: I'll let them know.
Lucia: 同志们烧烤组说外面现在火挺好的
Lucia: Hey everyone, the BBQ team said the fire outside is going strong.
Lucia: 大家可以出来了好的
Lucia: You all can come out now.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:炮台啊这是
Jake: It's like a cannon here.
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Ah ah.
Lucia: 为什么这个草莓变得越来越多
Lucia: Why are there more and more strawberries?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈完了这个要弄4个哈
Jake: Hahahahaha, we need to make four of these.
Lucia: 咱草莓不够啊
Lucia: We don't have enough strawberries.
Lucia: 哈哈有有有
Lucia: Haha, we have some.
Tasha: 已经没有了吧
Tasha: They're almost gone, right?
Lucia: 还有几个
Lucia: There are a few left.
Tasha: 哦我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Jake:这个可以弄一个
Jake:可以可以你是怎么弄完你说
Jake: Alright, how did you finish this? Tell me.
Lucia: 可以
Tasha: 没关系再把前面几个点缀点缀
Tasha: It's okay, just add some decorations to the earlier ones.
Jake:哦OK OK
Tasha: 后面每个都各有风格
Tasha: Each one has its own style.
Jake:对这个怎么办呢
Jake: So, what do we do about this?
Tasha: 您随意吧
Tasha: 你已经随意过头了哈
Tasha: You already went too far, haha.
Jake:弄个联动哈哈哈
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 哈梦幻联动
Tasha: Haha, a dreamy collaboration.
Lucia: 双重狂喜
Lucia: 可以
Jake:可以
Jake:双子塔
Jake: Twin Towers.
Lucia: 不是这是可以录的吗
Lucia: Can we record this?
Jake:哈哈哈倒了
Jake: Hahaha, it fell over.
Tasha: 双子塔是什么意思啊
Tasha: What does the Twin Towers mean?
Jake:对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 要不要记录一下时间
Lucia: Should we record the time?
Jake:哈哈哈确实不能说
Jake: Haha, we really shouldn't say.
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: It's that one.
Jake:呃马来西亚吉隆坡
Jake: Uh, Kuala Lumpur, Malaysia.
Jake:合合理了吧
Jake: Does it make sense now?
Lucia: 嗯特别合理
Lucia: Hmm, very reasonable.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:就是双子塔
Jake: It's the Twin Towers.
Jake:有很多吧
Jake: There are many, right?
Jake:咱也不说那一个
Jake: Let's not mention that one.
Lucia: 那你加这一句
Lucia: Then you add this sentence.
Jake:就合理了
Jake: Then it makes sense.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: Looks so good.
Tasha: 逐渐变稀
Tasha: Gradually thinning.
Lucia: 是因为树热了吗
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Tasha: ok
Tasha: 搬出去吧
Lucia: 特别棒
Lucia: Awesome.
Jake:开饭了
Jake: Dinner is served.
Jake:来这是餐前甜点还是餐后甜点
Jake: Is this a pre-dinner dessert or post-dinner dessert?
Alice:鸡翅好了
Alice: The chicken wings are done.
Alice:每人拿一个吧
Alice: Everyone take one.
Jake:哈餐中甜点
Jake: Haha, mid-dinner dessert.
Jake:哦这个怎么倒的呀
Jake: Oh, how did you pour this?
Lucia: 等待你拍完哈
Lucia: Waiting for you to finish taking the photo.
Shure: 不不不它就那么倒着它正正好
Alice:啊就是让那样亮一点的
Alice: Ah, just make it a bit brighter.
Jake:啊就更近一点是吧
Jake: Ah, just a bit closer, right?
Shure: 不是更近一点是那个角度打光刚刚好
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 都是牛肉吧好像
Lucia: It's all beef, I think.
Shure: 然后还有鸡翅鸡翅特香
Tasha: 哪呢
Shure: 这呢
Shure: 这都是祖传八辈的手艺
Jake:哪了这个
Jake: Where is this?
Tasha: 杨老师洗的筷子在哪
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 你洗的筷子在哪
Jake:我洗的筷子在这
Jake: My washed chopsticks are here.
Tasha: 我没有用过
Jake:嗯那还有一个我也为谁了
Jake: Hmm, then there's one more, who is it for?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: what's worng
Lucia: 总感觉
Lucia: Always feels like...
Lucia: 这双看起来并不像没用过的样子
Lucia: These don't look unused.
Lucia: 来冲一下吧
Lucia: Let's rinse them.
Tasha: 哦开吉他了
Tasha: Oh, the guitar is on.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯啊谢谢
Lucia: Hmm, thank you.
Lucia: 我说这双看起来并不像没用过的样子
Lucia: I said these don't look unused.
Jake:这双看起来并不像没用过的样子
Jake: These don't look unused.
Lucia: 我冲一下来着
Lucia: I'll rinse them.
Jake:哦呦
Jake: Oh, wow.
Lucia: 呃不是您在干嘛
Lucia: Uh, what are you doing?
Jake:好烫啊
Jake: So hot.
Jake:好烫啊我靠
Jake: So hot, damn.
Lucia: 啊终于吃掉了
Lucia: Ah, finally ate it.
Lucia: 这双啊谢谢
Lucia: These, ah, thanks.
Lucia: 这双就先撂在这里面吧
Lucia: Let’s just leave this pair here for now.
Lucia: 算了我也不想冲他了
Lucia: Never mind, I don't want to confront him either.
Jake:真的希望你能理清
Jake: Really hope you can figure this out.
Shure: 若没交心
Shure: 怎么说明
Shure: 我真的爱
Katrina: 来给你录一个
Shure: 你别录了你别录了
Shure: 算了算了丢人了
Alice:盘子我觉得趁热吃好吃
Alice: I think the dish tastes better when hot
Alice:来盘吧
Alice: Let's grab a plate
Jake:今天的架子鼓打打怎么样
Jake: How about playing the drums today?
Lucia: 还用这个盘吗
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah
Lucia: 嗯小心
Alice:离我近点
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah
Alice:趁热吃吧
Alice: Eat while it's hot
Lucia: 呃你不来电吗
Lucia: Uh, aren't you interested?
Alice:嗯闻着饭味我就有点
Alice: Hmm, just smelling the food makes me...
Lucia: 哎真的吗
Lucia: Oh really?
Jake:呃可能知道
Jake: Uh, maybe you know.
Lucia: 嗯让我想想
Lucia: Hmm, let me think.
Jake:应该知道吧
Jake: You should know, right?
Shure: 拿手的我跟你讲
Lucia: 能够到吗
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 那我就放这了
Shure: 好唱完你就带上了吧
Tasha: 什么就带上了
Shure: 耳机就带上了
Jake:来吃一个
Jake: Come, have a bite.
Jake:吃个什么呢我去
Jake: What should we eat, I wonder?
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:好吃
Jake: Tasty.
Tasha: 吃到爆浆了吗还没有
Tasha: Did you get to the juicy part? Not yet?
Jake:还没还没打开
Jake: Not yet, still hasn't burst.
Tasha: 成为主厨哈哈
Tasha: Becoming the head chef, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 怎么能什么都知道呢哈哈
Lucia: How can you know everything, haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 我学什么
其他人：我说你去学个医吧
其他人：我本来都快睡着了
其他人：被你唱醒了
其他人：你去对着植物人唱
其他人：说不定能给人叫醒
Shure: 你不没带耳机吗
其他人：你知道我为什么摘下来吗
Shure: 你好烦啊